economía en france 24 me acompaña en el
estudio daniel hablando con daniela muy
buenas noches comenzamos hablando del
fondo monetario internacional que mejoró
las perspectivas para este año por lo
menos ahora santiago buenas noches pues
no solamente al fondo monetario
internacional sino también varios
organismos multilaterales están
esperanzados en que la economía global
va a crecer más de lo que se perdía el
año pasado el fm y cree que se quedó
corto con su proyección de crecimiento
de 5.5 por ciento en 2021 por eso es
posible que lo revise al alza en su
próximo informe según anticipó su
directora gerente cristalina georgieva
esperamos una mayor aceleración en parte
debido a las políticas de respaldo
adicionales como el nuevo paquete fiscal
en eeuu y en parte también debido a la
recuperación esperada por las vacunas en
muchas economías avanzadas a final de
año
look else improve overol
pero aunque las perspectivas han
mejorado en general están divirtiendo
peligrosamente entre los países y las
regiones
en regiones también hablemos ahora de
las empresas de eeuu que van a recibir
más ayudas por parte de washington para
afrontar la pandemia del cob el 19
santiago de este miércoles iba a expirar
el llamado programa de protección para
nóminas para ayudar a las empresas
pequeñas a sobrevivir durante la
pandemia el presidente yo by the end
firmó este martes la extensión por dos
meses hasta el 31 de mayo de ese
programa este es un plan federal que
ofrece préstamos a las compañías que
pueden ser condenados si mantienen el
número de personas contratadas en cierto
nivel el programa fue creado hace un año
y formaba parte del primer paquete de
estímulo al que dio luz verde el
congreso por 22 billones de dólares sin
embargo santiago también hay que
recordar que fue muy polémico en sus
inicios porque se descubrió que muchas
empresas recibieron doble préstamo y
también que varios miles de millones
quedaron en los bolsillos de familias
ricas y poderosas
hablemos ahora de brasil que se está
recuperando allí los empleos que fueron
perdidos durante el inicio y durante la
crisis sanitaria desatada por la
pandemia pues el ministerio de economía
informó que en febrero de este año la
creación de empleos fue más del doble
que la del mismo mes del año pasado
fueron un poco más de 400.000 frente a
200.000 la cifra resulta de restar 169
millones de contrataciones menos 1,3
millones de despidos en este mes en este
país de más de 200 millones de
habitantes sólo hay 40 millones con
contrato formal es decir apenas es una
quinta parte y santiago la informalidad
es bastante amplia el desempleo por su
parte cerró el año pasado el 13,5 por
ciento el más alto desde que inició la
nueva serie estadística en 2012 o sea
que la población económicamente activa
de 100 millones de personas 3,4 millones
no tenían un empleo a finales de 2021 y
si habrá si le va bien a la región le va
bien pero argentina también consiguió
reducir levemente su deuda pública un
avance para la economía de este país una
pequeña buena noticia porque el año
pasado
la deuda externa bruta del país cerró en
272 mil millones de dólares que es un
poco menos de los 278 mil millones que
registraba un año antes sin embargo aquí
viene la noticia mala y es que esto no
tiene un gran efecto sobre el altísimo
nivel de endeudamiento de este país de
hecho el presidente argentino alberto
fernández reclamó el lunes antes
naciones unidas- que la crisis del
'hobbit' 19 debería ser aprovechada para
crear un nuevo marco de regulación sobre
alivio de deuda pública de los países
argentinas pudo reestructurar el año
pasado una deuda que tenía con
acreedores externos por 66 mil millones
de dólares pero ahora le queda otra por
44 mil millones con el fondo monetario
internacional y todavía no ha podido
renegociar la de hecho santiago la
vicepresidenta del país cristina
fernández fue muy clara hace una semana
y dijo no podemos pagar nuestras deudas
porque no tenemos por qué así de
sencillo indicadores la bolsa de nueva
york cerró en rojo y termina una buena
racha de cuatro días para su principal
índice el dow jones de industriales- en
europa hubo alzas genera
gracias a las mejores perspectivas del
fondo monetario internacional y en
américa latina la bolsa de sao paulo
encadenó su cuarta subida consecutiva la
cifra es día para hacer 6400 millones de
dólares en ayuda humanitaria parecería
que prometió la comunidad internacional
esto en una conferencia de donantes
organizada por la unión europea y la onu
en el décimo aniversario de la guerra
hay una gran contribución de los países
europeos en ese aporte a siria muchas
gracias daniela por actualizar nos del
mundo económico es todo por el momento
aquí en france24 siga con nuestra
programación buenas noches
[Música]